I'm 2,000 years old and I remember when  we used to open up the door and just  like to kiss be there will be part of  our trial period response so far it's  just incredible it's just a security  peace of mind the stories we've been  hearing there's really inspirational  it's completely safe sure it is remedies  can be subjective they may not be  totally accurate and they're often  emotional I don't remember anything it's  a total blank picture what you saw  did you see the vehicle that hit the  pedestrian I didn't see the actual crash  you might have asked you a few questions  I just saw to you  this accesses your memories of what  happened  I don't care what you doing your all  time private stuff is private stuff  [Music]  you